welcome to the global roundtable this
series focuses on the future of economic
competition I'm Parag Khanna joined by a
very distinguished panel including dumby
samoy Oh Daniel Altman and anon Gareth
hearthis can America compete the United
States is actually the second largest
economy in the world behind the European
Union and we know that China has
surpassed Japan to be the third largest
economic entity in the world but what
really matters is who's up and who's
down in different sectors of the economy
America is creating jobs in some areas
and losing jobs in others so what is it
going to take for America to be the most
competitive power a huge number of
Americans are increasingly themselves
not competitive within the country and
and in the world and that is a much more
serious issue than the question of is
America going to be kind of number one
two or three in that in that macro
ranking one of our great benefits in the
space race was that we had the GI Bill
we took all of these people and gave
them a lot more education than they had
before so when technological change
affected the way that an economy would
grow they'd be able to participate we
need a new GI Bill for people who are
dislocated by globalization just as they
were by the war fundamentally the world
needs the United States to really focus
on innovation and R&D because that is
actually what people around the world
are willing to pay America for we're
still happy to pay for innovation in
science is still happy to pay in
innovations in healthcare and medicine
but the issue here is that that's still
a very small proportion of the American
economy we've been hearing though about
worker retraining and the to America's
problem ever since John Edwards in the
2004 u.s. presidential election here we
are seven years later and we don't have
that GI Bill to retrain the masses for
new industries nor do we have a
consensus on exactly what they should be
retrained for we're really at the same
place we've been for a decade so really
how do we get out of it one of the ways
we can do that is by letting the private
sector solve the problem in the
market-based approach what we don't have
in this country in most industries is a
market for training so there's no reason
for me to invest in a worker if I think
that worker might leave my company and
I'll get no compensation for the
training well India is a country that is
growing tremendously by investing in the
skills of its people however that too is
not jobless growth but it certainly
isn't speaking to the masses of Indian
society what's happening in India is
India's learnt the lesson of an older
America which is if you get social
right to your point a lot of other
things work without you having to do
much even if you don't build the roads
you should you don't Electrify the
villages you should to the extent that
you create a fire of people wanting to
be mobile believing in mobility and
having some means to do it it's
reasonably self-sustaining this country
is losing that assumption the ordinary
middle-class lower middle class people
in this country are losing the
assumption that any other fate for them
is possible it's very interesting that
what we've agreed is that America does
need some kind of comprehensive program
to strengthen the capacity of his
workers to compete and yet at the same
time the market is going to decide what
it is that they're going to be best at
doing so very interesting insights here
on the future of competition in the
global economy more on that and other
relevant topics at big thing calm